hi friends are you ready to blast off
into outer space because this week is
nothing short of mind-blowing professor
Adam Frank is an astrophysicist at the
University of Rochester and author and a
founder of the NPR blog 13.7 cosmos and
culture now you may have heard him
recently on Joe Rogan's podcast and
that's where I fell in love with the
material that he works on in short today
we're going to find out are we alone in
the universe par at least what's the
likelihood that we're alone in the
universe
this episode honestly ranks as my
favorite one that I've recorded so far
it felt like every two minutes there was
some insane new statistic that I'd never
heard of or insight that I'd never
thought of before from how humans could
colonize the galaxy in as little as
seven hundred thousand years to where
the future descendants of the human race
are heading and the implications of
global warming with an awful lot more
thrown in this episode really is
jam-packed
hopefully you'll love this episode as
much as me and if you do I'm going to
ask a favor for the first time since I
started the podcast if you enjoy it
please share it with a friend
one friend two friends fire it in a
group chat screen shot the Apple
podcasts image or copy the link to
listen from Spotify however you do it I
don't mind but sharing this podcast and
increasing the number of exposures that
we get is a real key for me over the
coming months and if you could help me
in that way you'll be really appreciated
coming up soon we have the long-awaited
life hacks 105 me John Ian Yusuf back in
the hot seat again to give you our
favorite tips for a productive and
efficient life along with some slightly
more useless
tips as well we'll leave that for you to
make your own mind up about in the
meantime it's Adam Frank's turn to take
the microphone here we go
[Music]
professor Adam Frank how are you it's
great to be here thanks for having given
me the opportunity no worries at all
where in the world are you at the moment
um currently in my office at the
University of Rochester in beautiful
upstate New York that sounds lovely and
tomorrow's your birthday right Mars my
birthday gonna party like it's my
birthday fifty-six means that probably
it's like chill out and play video games
yeah well do you know 56 56 or fifty
sixteen it could be exactly the same
thing yeah fantastic right let's get
into it
so what what what is the likelihood that
we're the only instance of life in the
universe yeah what so that is a that's a
fifty million dollar question and you
know depending on how you wanna argue it
you can get you know different kinds of
opinions but what we did my collaborator
and I did a couple years ago is we used
the actual empirical data from the
Kepler results the you know the
basically our studies of exoplanets we
now recognize that there are exoplanets
everywhere pretty much every star you
see in the sky has a world at least one
world going around it and so what we did
is we use that data to at least set a
limit on the kind of answer you want to
give and so here's you know with science
often the most important thing is to
what question can you answer with the
data you have yeah so it's all of that
exoplanet data this question we could
ask was how um how bad does the
probability per planet have to be for us
to be alone like deeply and truly alone
and it turns out that given what we now
know the only way that we are the first
the only time it's ever happened in
civilization has happened in cosmic
history is if the probability per planet
of making a civilization is one in ten
billion trillion
that's a pretty big number yeah well I
mean it said well it's that the big
number is the number of planets the
number but it's a pretty small number
for Internet
yeah the odds of us being alone so yeah
right as you say that's your right to
point out that really what's important
here is how many um habitable zone
planets there are how many planets there
are where life has had the chance to run
the experiment right of forming life and
then the life going on to become
intelligent and a civilization forming
and that that's yeah that number is 10
billion trillion there are 10 billion
trillion planets in the cosmos that are
in the right place for life to form so
the only way that it hasn't happened
before is if on every one of those 10
billion trillion planets somehow the
experiment failed and you know I think
those numbers now are so they're so
large that it really falls to the
pessimists to tell us - explain to us
how could nature run the experiment so
many times and what's happened here
never happened anywhere else I
understand
am I right in thinking that an
observation effect occurs with this
though that the odds could be actually
an awful lot less likely than one in ten
billion trillion and we would still be
the only potential viewer to see it it
could actually be in the other direction
right as well as it could be more likely
it could actually be less likely because
as far as we can see there's only one
instance right but we haven't really
told me yeah so let me just address that
question so what we really were able to
do the thing that we could put a data
driven limit on was how bad would the
probability have to be yeah in order for
us to be alone so so like the actual
probability per habitable zone planet is
something you have to go out and do
observations and you know yes indeed
real data in terms of observations to
figure it out right so Nature has that
like nature over the course of cosmic
history has actually established for
each planet how you know it's all about
the processes of evolution and then
sociology if you want to get into
civilization so we don't know what those
are
don't know what nature actually did what
we could do is we could set a limit and
we called it the pessimism line as long
as nature is not this pessimistic as
long as nature hasn't set up her rules
of chemistry and physics and evolution
such that the odds are less than one in
ten billion trillion yeah and then it's
happened before and one in ten and
billion trillion is so small that it
seems like you don't nature doesn't have
to do much to get it above that and if
it's above that even if it's a little
bit above that it means this has
happened before this meaning a
technological civilization and that is
mind-blowing so okay it's running nature
is running the experiment an awful lot
of times right so if that's the case
then rolling it forward why is it likely
or why does it seem likely that we
haven't seen any galaxy conquering
civilizations right that's a great
that's a great question so that's
like--that's the Fermi paradox right yes
um and so the Fermi paradox actually
breaks down into two parts
so when Fermi you know Fermi's famous
question that he blurted over lunch in
1950 was because it's you know they've
been talking about aliens and he said
well where are they all right and so
that question eventually by people a
scientist like Hart and Tipler
eventually became what we now think of
as that Fermi paradox but really there's
two ways to think about it one is why
aren't they here now right why haven't
we as you said why haven't they landed
on the White House lawn the other part
is why haven't we seen them in our
observations right and so the second
part people often talk about the Silence
of the stars about you know what why are
there stars why haven't you know we've
seen alien intelligence and since no
signals and since then we haven't seen
it yet that we must be alone in the
universe but what they really don't
realize is that we hardly looked right I
think most people have this idea that
scientists have been scanning the skies
for alien signals for you know 50 years
and really you know there's no money for
it nobody's doing that so the number you
know that the amount of actual searching
we've done is minuscule as Jill tarter
says um if the you know if the ocean
is the amount of space parameter space
to you know actual stars that we have to
look at Radio fancies if that's the
ocean all we've looked at is a thimble
full of wool is that does that seem like
an appropriate analogy as well yeah
absolutely and so you know you look
symbol and say oh I didn't find any life
in the thimble and go well there you go
the whole oceans dead so you know so
people need to understand that really we
have just we barely begun to actually
search for evidence in among the Stars
telescopic evidence of alien of other
civilizations but when it comes to the
earth you know i'm visiting the earth
that is actually cuz we're working on a
paper on that one that is a bit more of
a problem but there's kind of lots of
ways around that like maybe maybe
interstellar travel is really really
really hard yeah right and and it's so
hard that nobody gets to do it very much
actually that's kind of a on my opinion
so so you know the first part of the
Fermi paradox I worry less about and the
second part of the part of the Fermi
paradox is that even a paradox because
we haven't even looked yet so I would
say the question is completely open
about whether or not there are other
civilizations out of it so in terms of
the Fermi paradox still being used as a
basis for inquiry it seems like the the
current field has moved forward a little
bit and that the questions have now
evolved a little bit more so with that
in mind your recent research how
accurate or how important is it to still
consider the Drake Equation for as a
basis for inquiry and could you briefly
explain what the Drake Equation is for
that yes the Drake Equation has a really
amazing history so Frank Drake was a
radio astronomer who in the 19 1959 he
was the first guy to ever point a radio
telescope at a star and actually look
for a signal from you know for an
intelligent signal some kind of signal
that could be interpreted as being from
civilizations and that was really the
beginning spoke so both Fermi and Drake
in this is you're all happening in the
field you say the 50 the fifties have
[ __ ] up for getting some search and some
aliens right well it was the beginning
really of us thinking scientifically
about EXO's
right people have been asking this
question as long as there's been people
do the stars are we the only ones the
only intelligent species in the universe
and people been asking that question you
can see it back to the Greeks but Furby
and Drake were the beginning of people
starting to ask this question
scientifically trying to ask a question
that you could actually formulate the
way that you could build a research
program from so Drake really he's the
first one to ever actually look you know
because now we actually had telescopes
that could do it and then um two years
after or a year after he does this you
know search people found out about it
you know it went Bo is big news and then
the United States government asked him
to hold a meeting on interstellar
communications and he invited you know
there's maybe 10 people at the meeting
Carl Sagan you know so other people and
he in order to set up the meeting he
wanted a way to sort of frame the agenda
and so he came up with this equation
which was basically it was an equation
for the number of civilizations that
that we could contact in the galaxy like
how many are out there and his equation
had 7 individual terms in it and each
term in the equation was really a sub
question so he asked um how many how
many stars are there in the galaxy how
many galaxies are there are sorry how
many planets what fraction of those
stars have planets the number of planets
in the habitable zone the right place
for life to form yeah around those
planets etc etc and so but that that way
of formulating it of breaking the
problem of how many civilizations are
there into a bunch of sub problems
that's what's enduring and his that
formulation has become so powerful for
us in terms of thinking about what you
need to get a civilization and that's
what we used in our own research we
modified the Drake Equation to get that
1 in 10 billion trillion number Wow okay
so it actually provided a framework feed
yeah move forward from that's really
interesting and it does still does I
think it's you know for what was really
it just supposed to be an agenda you
know for a meeting it turned out the
enormous leap oh that's awesome um so
this still if the chance of life only
occurring once appears to be pretty low
it
seems like it should have happened from
both the recent research that you've
done and the Drake Equation
we should have seen something by now
right I've read an awful lot about
Vaughn no von Neumann probes and there's
some crazy fast colonization statistics
that are cited for being able to take
over a galaxy for the listeners who
don't know von Neumann probes are
self-replicating robots that go to a
particular system they suck up some of
the resources they replicate themselves
and they go again is that right right
right right it's a way of settling the
solar system touching every star every
planetary system in the galaxy and yeah
in about 700,000 years you can cross the
entire going it like you know a tenth of
the speed of light you need about a
seven hundred thousand years you can
pretty much touch every system in the
galaxy ok so you know what why have we
not seen that yeah that's a really
interesting crime we're working on a
paper on this right now you look there's
a lot of papers at the moment to the
bone um the here's the interesting
question right the question the question
really should be when did they visit
right because it's entice oh there's
there's lots of ways out of this right
but but let me just say let's just
assume that there were colonizers you
know that there are settlers or there
was a species that wanted to settle you
know settle the different star systems
if they arrived 3 billion years ago
right and they lasted every
civilizations a finite lifetime right
nobody lasts forever so if they were
here 3 billion years ago and they lasted
for a million years which would be a
long time all evidence that they ever
existed is got Lisa Bertha yeah over so
deeply so you know you have to take both
space and time into account and so
that's one of things we're looking at
like how far back could they have
visited and still you know really left
some kind of evidence so so so that's
one way around it they just visited so
long that it happened but it happened
didn't happen you know close enough for
us to see evidence another thing is that
um like I said that you know von Neumann
machine
assumes a certain level of being able to
produce artificial intelligence we don't
know that's true yeah that's a nice
science fiction idea but we don't know
that's true
so and then you know if you meet if you
don't have von Oy machines and
artificial intelligence
then you need actual living beings to do
that and you know space travel building
a world ship are you familiar with the
idea of world ships or century ships no
so it's the idea that if you have to
like if we want to travel from one star
to the other and we don't have some kind
of super drive that can take us out yo
first of all the speed of light is a is
a limit as far as we know it's an
absolute physical limit we don't even
know if a warp drive is even physically
meaningful thing yeah so you know let's
just say the laws of physics that we
understand hold then you have to go at
the speed of light or less than that and
say let's say you could manage it would
be a miracle to be able to go up to ten
percent of the speed of light it would
still take you hundreds of years to get
to even the closest stars
so therefore you'd have to build the
ship that they call it a century ship or
a generation ship where you know you put
people in the ship and they'd have to
live their entire lives in the ship on
the way you know crossing over to the
next star live and die and live and die
and then there would be generations that
would never get off it and then finally
you may be born in the generation that
does actually get to see dry land so to
speak again yeah exactly right so that
could be like yeah it could be your
great-great grandchildren who actually
get there and that has all kinds of
issues moral issues like what does it
mean to condemn you know your future
generations to live in it in a tin can
their entire lives right a lot a lot of
great science fiction written on that
subject I just recently read a paper
where the the scientist estimated the
size of the economy that you would need
to be able to build one of those things
and it would basically you would need on
the order of like a thousand earth
economies you know in order to have the
resources to build a machine of that
scale
right right and that was really
surprised by that and it just sort of
speaks to the fact that you know we
always have these science fiction ideas
like Oh technology's gonna progress
endlessly but you know we don't really
know if that's true their main real be
real limits that we can't get around um
and so you know it's quite possible that
it's just so expensive and hard to
travel but
Queen the Stars that you rarely do it I
was gonna say so what what can you see
as being the most likely hurdles for
civilizations to get over before they
can colonize the galaxy is it is it a
pandemic is it resource exhaustion is it
malignant AI is a combination of the few
I think there's a great is it a great
barrier or the climate change and
climate change is is the first major
hurdle because the difference between
climate change and say nuclear war or
pandemics well but maybe not panic but
you know you know rtai a we don't even
know if AI is possible um nuclear war
you know there could be some species
that are like I'm not building those
things that's crazy you know but climate
change you know this is the thesis of
the book
everybody gets climate change if you
build a world girdling civilization as I
like to say um there's no way there's
almost no way around climate change
because at least triggering it because
if you're using that much energy to
build a large-scale civilization the
planet which is a giant thermodynamic
system has got a notice so you know
triggering climate change I think is
universal and the question is whether or
not you're smart enough to make it
through West enough to negate the
effects I guess before it makes it
uninhabitable for you because by its
very nature evolution has allowed us to
evolve on a planet which is we are
fine-tuned for it rather than it being
fine-tuned for us and as we begin to
make amends to that climate we can
actually make it in inhospitable for
ourselves to exist on right that's
exactly it
you know people often talk about climate
change is being like oh we've gotta save
the earth you know as if the earth was
like a furry little bunny and it's you
know the earth is gonna be just fine you
know there's there's literally nothing
we could do
to destroy the biosphere well change the
biosphere we'll set it on a new path but
the biosphere will be just fine it's us
right we're the wagon a folks did you
put an exec you put it beautifully it's
you know the earth
we're fine-tuned to the planet not the
other way around and so if we push the
climate hard enough and it drifts off
into a new state as it has many times
before you know the this complex
technological society is the thing that
probably
won't make it yeah Wow um you've touched
on a term there that I did want to I did
actually want to get your thoughts on
it's a little bit of a segue do you or
do you have any ideas yourself as an
explanation for why the universe seems
fine-tuned for life
wow that is uh that is such a powerful
and profound question and I don't
[Laughter]
because no no that problem speaks decide
now we're doing you know we're heading
off into a slightly different territory
but it's fun territory so we should talk
about it um you know the laws of physics
right we there's there's a lot of
questions about why the laws of physics
look the way they do the universal
constants and such like that right yeah
exactly right you know so there's
there's you know anybody who's taken
high school physics remembers Newton's
laws of gravity and there's that G
sitting in there there's this number
that just sits there and you're like
where'd that come from it's like well
the universe just gave it to us
you're the value of it right six point
six seven times 10 to the minus 11
Newton kilogram meter squared
um I think that might be it I might
score points for getting that ready up
you know so you know why didn't you
choose that value of the constant and
not a little bit different and then
there's all these other constants that
go along with the laws that we
understand and it seems like if any of
those laws were just slightly different
then life as we know it couldn't have
formed and this has been you know a
major question for physics why did the
universe choose that now some
philosophers look at that problem and
they're like look it's not a big deal
it's just the ones you ended up with
right there's not you know I mean if I
go outside it's raining today you know
if that's that's the day you found that
it was raining it's not you know it's
not something strange something that
needs to be explained you know there's
there's past history etc but of course
with the universe if there's only one
universe then you know at some point you
run into you run out of past history
yeah so for some philosophers this is
not a problem it's just a given for
physicists we feel like there could have
been you know that the we tend and this
is the problem we tend to think of the
universe as being like a an experiment
on a table like
on the experiment differently yes so
maybe I could have run but maybe that's
the problem right maybe so I think this
is really a problem both in physics and
philosophy because here's the question
how do you do
the science of something that has only
happened once yeah you know how do you
talk about the probability how do you
talk about the statistics of something
that you don't have statistics for you
know and so you know in physics now I am
NOT I'm I'm not a big fan of like things
like the multiverse and string theory I
think there's real problems with that
and so the idea that like oh you know
people some people are really very happy
about the idea there's lots of universes
there popping off all the time and then
the reason why the universe appears
fine-tuned for life is we just happen to
live in a mediocre universe and and
that's the that's the value that most of
the universe's have gotten yeah yeah I
think that whole way of thinking first
of all there's no data for it you know
so it's it's it's it's it's a fiction
and second of all it comes from
mistaking this one time thing which is
the universe for you know something
that's reproducible that that you could
that that's like an experiment on a
table Jill Stein completely yeah yeah so
the big that you know I'm you just had
that beam - Seder on your very very
recently did ya she she had a lot a lot
to say about the dogma and the ideology
which appears to be really really
prevalent in physics I was very
interested in shocked to find out that
not only are physicists humans but
they're also that are also subject to
the emotions and the cognitive biases
that the rest of us are right right well
the problem is and so I really I agree
with a lot of things she has to say and
the problem it's not all physics it's
just this what we might call the
frontiers like the absolute frontiers of
space and time and cosmology right and
the problem for them is particularly
when it comes to particle physics is
that there's there's no data that they
run that we're kind of we run to the
edge of where we can get data and you
know science has got to have data and if
you run out of data then
you become subject to all of the
cognitive biases etc so you know things
like the multiverse and such to me are
are enigmatic of the fact that those
branches of physics as exciting as they
are have kind of reached their limit of
what of having data and so we got to go
back really now and think much more
deeply and philosophically we have to
rely to get dressing for lot of these
philosophical I'm a big fan of
philosophy and I think it's very
important in science when you run into
these boundaries so yeah so fine-tuning
presents a real challenge but I think
you know there's gonna be scientific
answers to it but it may take us and
really exotically an interesting place
it's as big of a question as you as we
can get to right so let's get let's get
back onto the core tenants so um the
Kardashev scale yeah I absolutely love
this concept I think it's it's so cool I
just think it's such an awesome way to
categorize civilizations and it gives
you a real sense of all and is it's
quite grounding as well you know when we
think we look back at 1,000 years ago
even a hundred years ago or you think
how far have we come and you realize
just how much further than there is to
go but it's also and yeah and also built
into it is an assumption that I think we
have also stuck we've realized how wrong
that assumption is so let's just go
through what the Kardashev scale is
right yes so what it's on the same page
ok so just as Frank Drake was riding
down the Drake Equation
there were Kardashev was a astronomer in
Russia who was also interested in
extraterrestrial civilisations and he
came up with this idea cuz he was
actually thinking about what you should
look for and he came up with this idea
that civilizations would naturally
progress through three different
categorizable stages or types and a
Titan was all based on energy and type
one civilization would be a civilization
that could harness all of the energy
available to its home planet and that's
basically solar energy or stellar energy
or they go although they could harvest
all the energy falling on the planet
from the star yes then a type 2 would be
a civilization that could harvest all
the energy that
came from the star itself by say you
know wrapping a giant sphere around the
star with solar panels on the inside and
harvesting you know the entire energy
output of the star yes a Type three was
where a civilization could harvest all
the energy coming from their home galaxy
with its four hundred billion stars yeah
so so that is like you know that idea is
also been you know both for science
fiction and for people thinking about
extraterrestrial intelligence that has
become you all kind of a keystone idea
that a lot of people have worked with
the developed and we are about we're
about a naught point seven right I think
a core yeah so I think I was Carl Sagan
you know was the master of all of this
did a calculation and said it log in log
scale we're at a point seven but here's
the thing here's you know that for me
what's really important right so um you
know my whole thesis in my book is that
we've been looking at climate change all
wrong we think of climate change is some
kind of weird political issue or you
know it's it's the question is did we or
didn't we change you know the climate
but in fact actually when you look at it
from you know a kind of the ten thousand
light years any any EXO civilization any
civilization on a planet will just be
something that the the biosphere of that
planet evolves it's just going to just
like there were dinosaurs and grasslands
a technological civilization is going to
be one of the things that's possible for
a biosphere to evolve yeah and when it
does that civilization is no less
subject to the laws of the biosphere to
the laws of planets and how planets
evolve then dinosaurs or grasslands
right lately do you think that we are
potentially wrapped up in our own genius
to a degree that's exactly the problem
we think this goes back to this idea of
like oh my God we're gonna destroy the
planet we just have we just have a very
large view of a larger view of ourselves
than we deserve right we're you know we
are what the planet is what the
biosphere and the planet is doing now
you know and there's no guarantee we're
what's gonna the planets going to be
doing a thousand years from now and
we're
I'm gonna destroy the planet we don't
have that kind of power yeah that the
the concept to say that we are going to
destroy the planet it's it's all based
on perspective of what exists in destroy
our right because to destroy the planet
by melting the polar ice caps it's
probably gonna be pretty good for some
fish we're gonna be pretty [ __ ] for us
right what they mean is that we're going
to change the nature right we're gonna
change right well alter we will we will
move the biosphere into a new state
which probably won't include us anymore
right but we're not gonna destroy the
biosphere in fact the biosphere has gone
through many changes including the only
reason we're here is because of a mass
extinction 65 million years ago right so
mass extinctions from the from the
biospheres perspective can be an
opportunity to fill niches right so I'm
now clearly we don't want to trigger a
mass extinction now because we depend on
all that biodiversity for our own
complex civilization but the idea that
like somehow what we're gonna do is
going to destroy the biosphere is just
insane and that goes to the mistake in
Kardashev scale because the Kardashev
scale was all about energy use right and
it was a very kind of 1960s
you know shiny future kind of science
fiction idea right so in the 1960s you
know we had all of you look at the
movies and then everybody's flying
around in gleaming perfect spaceships
and yeah and so there is the idea that
if you just could you know marshal
enough energy if you had enough energy
you could bring a planet to heal you
know you can almost as if the technology
was just gonna be a byproduct of of time
going by and they simply resource
acquisition that was the only that was
gonna be the only hurdle to get over
right right and the lesson of climate
change and what we call the Anthropocene
so I talk a lot in the book about the
the idea of the Anthropocene which is
this new geologic era that we've
triggers the human dominated era so the
last ten thousand years we've been in
what we call the Holocene the last in
the interglacial period and now we push
the earth out of the Holocene oh we're
doing it we're pushing it into a new era
which people call the anthro pissed
what anthro person is in anthropology
right yes yes nice eater Matt nice
entomology of the word right right it's
gonna be an era where human effects
dominate even if we're gone we will
already push the planet into that era by
our activity up to now so so what the
lesson of the Anthropocene which goes
against what Kardashev was saying was
that it's not just energy it's not just
how much energy you have available to
you you know you've already got a planet
and a biosphere which is incredibly
powerful and it's got its own rules you
know and those rules are more are just
as much about entropy and the second law
of thermodynamics as they are about just
harvesting energy so um you know carne
chef Carter chef doesn't take into
account that by using all of that energy
you feed back on the planet in ways that
could end your civilization so you know
III think it's I mean I love Kardashev
scale but I think it's really important
to notice that we've gone now beyond
Kardashev scale to recognize that it's
more complicated the transition for
civilizations at least planetary
civilizations is more complex than just
harvesting energy yeah yeah it
definitely seems to be so so regardless
of how unlikely it seems that we're
alone at the moment we are as far as we
can tell right and if we are on our own
what implications does this have for our
behavior both personally and globally
and environmentally it sounds to me it
seems to me an awful lot like the stakes
have been raised for everybody well yes
okay I'll think about this in two weeks
so on one level right we're not there's
no other planet for us to go to you know
Mars I'm a big fan of you know settling
the solar system and I kind of think of
it as the prize we get for making it
through climate change but you know Mars
there's we're not gonna be going to Mars
we're not gonna get enough people to
Mars any time soon
to you know to make you know living on
Earth easier so that's out of the
picture but I do think I from my
perspective we now know so much
about planets because of the we visited
every kind of planet in the solar system
and we've also now know that there's all
these other planets and we also know an
amazing amount about Earth's 4.5 billion
year history that even if we don't even
if we haven't found xxo civilizations as
I like to say we now have you know we
have good arguments for why they should
have existed you know that they're
they're probably what I would say is
they probably have existed in the past
doesn't mean there's anybody around now
but but we know enough now to ask
ourselves what is the generic
consequence of a civilization emerging
from a biosphere are you saying you
would you say that it's inevitable that
any civilization unless they get
something incredibly right are
incredibly fortunate that this is this
is part this is par for the course this
is you're along for the ride that's
exactly what I'm saying
I think and I think that's that's why
it's really important to start thinking
seriously about EXO civilizations
because what we realize is we're just
one of many right and and that the stage
you know of we now know there's so many
planets that you know unless nature is
insanely biased against it this has
happened before it's probably happened a
lot and everybody's triggered climate
change becomes is you know what on
average how long on average does anybody
last and what do you have to do on
average in order to make it through
right so in that way what's happening
with us we're just cosmic teenagers
right yeah I get that
da F do you think that by framing the
question in this way that it takes
global warming a little bit out of the
political sphere and into the
civilization [ __ ] we need to fix this
fear I think it changes everything and
that's why you know as the book has come
out you know it's been great that the
books gotten a lot of attention I've had
the opportunity to talk with a lot of
people about this oh you know and some
people are always like well what is this
change and for me it changes everything
because you know this to you as I like
to say you can't solve a problem until
you understand it and you can't
understand it until you can tell its
story and when it comes to climate
change we've been telling the wrong
story and
because we've been telling the wrong
story that's one of the reasons why
after 30 years of knowing about it we
haven't done [ __ ] right you know the
Paris Accord was a great beginning but
it wasn't even close to dealing with
this you know and so the climate change
it seems either you end up with denial
people saying it's not happening or it
just seems so overwhelming the peoples
that their heads just turn off right
yeah I totally understand that you've
just got this distribution of both ends
of the curve people right I think
there's nothing that we can do while
people think we don't need to do
anything right right and then the people
who are even you don't want to do
something about it you just get locked
into this thing like oh my god human
beings we just suck we're disease on the
planet you know and it becomes this
really negative story and with this when
you look at it from the the
astrobiological perspective as I like to
say you know from the 10,000 light your
view you see like look climate change is
not a problem that you have to make go
away it is a it's a transition and an
expected and predictable transition that
is dangerous and that you have to
navigate right nobody says adolescence
has to go away right when your kid turns
12 you're not like oh my god stop with
the adolescence yeah you know gonna have
to go through adolescence adolescence is
a very dangerous phase not everybody
makes it through and you know what you
hope for is the wisdom to be able to
make that transition and when you come
out on the other side you have enormous
opportunities and potential if you make
it through the other side yeah so where
do we go from here what are the
directions that we can go in from 2018
well I think the first thing is this
beginning you know the big the
recognition that as we talk about
climate change is the recognition that
climate change is really our Copernican
revolution right so you know you look at
the Copernican revolution and before the
Copernican revolution everybody you know
went outside and they saw the Sun you
know over the eastern horizon they said
oh you know the earth is the center of
the universe and the Sun is orbiting the
Earth and then after the Copernican
revolution everyone was like no the
earth is just another planet orbiting
the Sun like the whole universe changed
everything and it had huge consequences
for politics and philosophy and religion
you know it was a fundamental transition
in how human beings saw themselves in
the world
yeah and that's what climate changes
it's the moment when we are forced like
many other civilizations across cosmic
space and time we are forced to grow up
we are forced to enter into our maturity
and so that's the first thing to
understand and that to understand that
actually it's you know it's very
dangerous but it also signals something
I mean this sounds weird but there's a
way in which we could be proud of
triggering climate change right we are
we have with our cell art collective
project of civilization we change the
atmosphere of an entire planet right
that's not bad for a bunch of hairless
monkeys you know so the real question
now is okay we triggered climate change
we didn't do it on purpose right it was
a it was an unintended consequence of
just doing what we've been doing forever
which is using energy to build
civilization I think that's it I think
that's such a good point that you
touched on it earlier on people think
you humans suck and were discussing to
the planet and we're mistreating it and
all the rest of things you know should
there are some energy companies
throughout the years that could have
probably been more responsible but I'd
bet that I would wager that none of them
went out of the way and thought you know
I really fancy waking up and doing today
I really fancy [ __ ] up the planet
like no one thought that right now at
the beginning nobody knew right so when
we discovered you know when we
discovered oil and coal right you know
all we were doing was the exact same
thing we've been doing since you know
the birth of Agriculture we were like
you know we started using animals to do
work first we started using their poop
to burn you know and we found oil and we
were like oh my god this [ __ ] is awesome
you know you can heat your home with it
you can build an internal combustion
engine I mean you know we didn't know
that we were gonna trigger climate
change with it we just built a great
civilization with it once we realized
that you know climate change was
happening a lot of the 1980s you know
then the companies who knew that it was
happening and purposely you know drove
climate denial or purposely you know
didn't do anything about it
yeah it's that now it does get to fall
now it does get to
they are gonna be the follow that will
lead to you know our civilization not
reaching its potential of us potentially
collapsing um but you know for most of
us right for you and me you know we
didn't purpose it's not like we're
[ __ ] for you know coming into a
world where we drive cars right I mean
you know now the question is as a
collective society can we make a
transition to a different kind of energy
infrastructure so you know it changes
that the whole way we think about this
we've got to understand that this is a
transition that we should have expected
you know and now that it's happening you
know we've got to marshal our forces and
see whether or not we've got the
evolutionary you know potential to make
the next step and and and have a you
know a long history in front of us yeah
definitely the evolutionary cojones to
keep on looking for gap up to the plate
because you know when you think about
okay there's all these civilizations out
there I think that have gone through
this before and you know lots of them
have probably not made it maybe some of
them didn't make it what was it that
distinguished to distinguish the winners
from the losers right conceptually what
what can you what can you think of what
can you conceive of that would get them
through it well you know so it's funny
so one of the things I talked about in
the book and that it was a recent paper
that we just published where we modeled
we did these sort of you know simplified
models of the interaction between a
civilization and it and a planet and a
planet as an ecosystem and what we
wanted to see sort of like what are the
generic kinds of histories you know once
and what we found is there were three
basic kinds of trajectory for a
civilization and planet together
the first was sustainability you
actually you know that the civilization
started using the planets energy it was
the the population went way up because
of it the planet started to heat up
because of it but you came to a nice
stable equilibrium you know the client
stopped heating and the populations came
to a steady state that was good right
and that was ok so that showed you that
at least you know from the mathematical
modeling yeah ok it is possible to have
sustainability yeah the other the other
two classes of
trajectory were a little bit more
worrisome one was just straight-out
collapse you know the population rose
really fast the planet heated up the
population overshot the carrying
capacity of the planet and they just
dropped like a stone he basically went
extinct as the planet just drove off
into an entirely new climate state so
that was bad and then the other one was
sort of like intermediate where you had
a huge die-off you didn't you know you
didn't go extinct but you lost 70% of
your population so you know from those
three different classes of trajectory
what it tells you is like okay it should
be possible to have and you know come to
some kind of equilibria some kind of
sustainability but you know you're gonna
have to NAB you're gonna have to be
really thoughtful and navigate these
treacherous waters to make sure you
don't end up on one of those other kinds
of trajectories and there's in the
future you know we're gonna make these
models more complex more realistic and
hopefully we'll be able to see really in
fine detail what distinguished the
winners from the losers amazing so in
this particular projection what is some
of the key elements is population
control something that we need to really
be be carefully thinking about or is
energy the first port of call is that
the greenhouse gases you know what are
the what's the low-hanging fruit so to
speak um yeah you know I mean I if I the
answer I give is gonna be it's not going
to be based on my models because the
models didn't have that kind of fine
detail in them yeah but I would see but
but okay but what I would certainly say
is it's not just population its energy
per capita right so you know um for
example if you look at like the energy
so here's a if you look at energy per
person and versus happiness or wellness
like you're the UN has a wellness index
and what you find is is that um you know
first countries that use very very
little energy and are very poor people
are pretty miserable right but then as
you ascend the amount of energy you use
you find people get you know their
wellness index goes up people are
happier but once you get to about
Italy's level of energy use it kind of
tops off so we like you know an average
American or Canadian uses way more
energy than the average Italian but
they're really not much happier right so
the question is can you find
if you've got 7 billion people on the
planet can you you know what's the right
amount of energy that each person can
get to have a fulfilling life right
maybe everybody doesn't get 3 cars you
know but you still get you know used to
get you get you know easy transportation
and you get to fly around every now and
then and you minimum effective dose
right that's exactly what it is and so
that's what I think we really have to
think about we have to recognize that
every kind of energy we use has a
consequence like even you know if we
switch to all renewables that doesn't
mean we're not going to have any impact
on the planet we're always gonna have an
impact on the climate the question is
how do we do how do we tune those
impacts so that actually we're helping
the biosphere rather than you know
hindering its own flourishing so who
does the responsibility lie with here is
it scientists to improve the science is
it politicians to improve the politics
is it individual people of the the
societies to alter their usage and
reduce their usage is it governments to
better educate those people I think it
falls - I mean you know really what it
falls to is it's the level I'd say it's
the level of cities or town you know
really cities on up right um because you
know I mean you and I we should we
should recycle and we should be careful
about our you know our impacts on the
planet we should not practice ecological
hooliganism
you know like stuff with your crap in
the river cuz you just fell I feel I've
got LED bulbs in in the house you know
yeah yeah but but you know in the long
run you you know our individual actions
mean less than because this is really an
infrastructure problem right and it's
it's not much more than bad right and so
you know you and I can't control what
kind of energy comes into my house right
plug but I plug my thing in you know my
my you know my plug into the wall I get
electricity out of it but you know
there's only so much control I have over
where that how that energy was generated
right so it's really on the level of
what we you know so what we really need
to do is put pressure on governments
from the city level on up and companies
to to like make the sweep
infrastructure changes that we need in
order to solve this problem like you
know so the zeroth order we're gotta be
done with fossil fuels like that is the
simplest thing that we could do it
that's your number one low-hanging fruit
that's the law that is the low-hanging
fruit if we did that we would be so far
along the curve to a new kind of your
relationship with the biosphere it's so
simple to be done I mean it's it's you
know building a new infrastructure is
non-trivial but on the other hand you
know we've done that a lot across
civilization I like to point out that um
here in Rochester there's a place I can
stand where I'm looking at the Erie
Canal which was this you know this canal
that ran across in New York State it was
a big deal when it was built in the
1830s and then um that was like the main
mode of creating wealth and
infrastructure you know of
transportation in 1830 but then around
the 1850s 1870s train lines came in and
I can come to I can stand on a place
where that trim one of those train lines
was put in and I can see the trend line
and then a little bit further than that
I can see the highway and then above
that I can see the airplanes landing
right so those are four different
transportation infrastructures that we
built in the space of you know a hundred
years yeah you know in 50 years and they
required enormous blood and and effort
and money and but we just built them and
in some cases we abandoned them right so
the idea of like that oh my god
switching from you know uh fossil fuels
to something else is impossible is just
like you just look at our recent history
and it's like that's what we're good at
me I overcome stuff right yeah that's
right our ingenuity so um you know
making that switch is important and it
has to happen at the higher levels
because one of the problems with climate
change is we were talking about before
is people feel like every choice they
make has like this overwhelming moral
consequence like oh my god left the
light on yeah yeah right I'm a horrible
person you know what the problem is
actually bigger than you individually so
for those of us who live in democratic
societies the real effort is not just
voting once right not just voting once
you know what do you know if we have an
election like in the United States you
know once a year we should be voting all
the time we should be showing up you
know we got it like in America in my
town I've got an opportunity to vote
probably every week I could go down to
the City Council and you know
push for responsible climate friendly
energy modalities you know I can help
choose the candidates I should make sure
that the candidate who's gonna run next
year is you know thinking about climate
change so that's what I say is really
you know the most important thing is to
put pressure on the you know the systems
that were part of um to affect change I
agree I think what's lovely about the
way that you've presented it is that
you've created the foundations for
reframing the the whole concept the
whole argument taking it out of the
political sphere to a degree making it
less of a emotionally charged and
passionate issue passionate topic right
and what's actually happening now is
it's like look this is happening don't
beat yourself up about it just work out
how the [ __ ] we can fix it right exactly
that's really the thing we should have
it's happening because it was supposed
to happen right that's really a thing of
course this happened the same wait the
same ways that you turn the light bulb
you turn a traditional light bulb on it
gives off light which is what you want
but it also gives off heat which is not
necessarily what you want a byproduct of
us developing as a civilization was this
effect on the biosphere yeah you didn't
mean for it to happen right now how do
we now how do we move forward right
that's exactly it that's exactly that's
not you know that's a really nice
analogy that idea of the light bulb
right yeah so like oh we were using
these light bulbs that did what we
wanted them to do but they had this
negative side effect oops
okay just [ __ ] change the light bulbs
man yeah you know it was in this one
that big a deal the people right the
problem is you know because of the
climate denial because there are people
who stand to lose a lot of money you
know if we make this change they've sort
of they've kept us from changing the
light bulbs right I know the allergy I
like to use is look you know when I was
when I was a young man we had this thing
called typewriters and there were these
big machines that you push buttons on
and you could write you know you write
things and then of course you know when
the computers came around you know came
in a nine that mid-80s the typewriters
all went away right that business just
went away if you if you owned a
typewriter company I'm sorry you're
screwed right right and now what's
happening is it's as if the typewriter
company somehow convinced the Gov
means to not allow computers to ever be
developed yeah right
Oh Computers man they're a bunch of tree
huggers you know technology I'm sorry
you're gonna lose money but like that's
capitalism pal
sorry yeah get yourself on that get
yourself on the forefront of what's
coming next so baby right right you know
so yeah I understand so to round up
what's your general sentiment at the
moment obviously you are as I would put
it your dick and balls in this
particular subject field at the moment
what what's your sentiment like can you
sometimes do you sometimes struggle to
have perspective can you see the wood
for the trees so to speak well you know
the great thing about being an
astronomer is it's all forest you know
the you know the great thing about being
astronomer is it gives you a superpower
and that is time right so you know it's
really you know the idea of thinking on
century timescales is just you know it
comes really easily because I'm trained
you know century to the ship millennia
timescales comes easily so you know in
that sense you know when I wear my
astronomer hat whatever's gonna happen
is gonna happen I don't know if we're
gonna make it but it really it doesn't
really matter because you've got a whole
universe out there you know our story is
just one story out of a very large book
of the universe and you know I really
feel very confident that there's other
places where this is happening and you
know maybe somebody makes it through if
I put my dad hat on because I got two
kids then I'm like holy [ __ ] we got to
do something so um but I am generally
optimistic you know things are pretty
bad right now but on the other hand
human beings have an enormous capacity
for resilience and optimization or you
know or yeah or resilience and
innovation excuse me and I really feel
like you know this is kind of the dark
the dark time before we really kick in
because you know I teach a lot of
students and I talk to students you know
Millennials and the younger generation I
find them to be pretty amazing pretty
amazing and pretty full of ideas and you
know I think we're gonna be able to do
it I think so as well
so Adam would you be able to tell the
listeners at home where they can find
you online please
I'll make sure that light of the Stars
alien worlds in the fate of the earth
will be linked in the description
tripping below I recommend everybody to
go and pick the book up
is there an audiobook version as well I
know a lot of listeners version yeah so
you can get those boats on your favorite
you know website Amazon obviously you
know a lot of people go there you can
get the book on my own if you want to
follow my stuff I'm on Twitter at Adam
Frank for their number four I also have
a facebook off their page I tend to do
most of my time on Twitter social media
wise and I also have a website
Adam Frank science.com and if you want
to you know send me a question or
something I'm very I suck at email so
it's gonna be very hard sometimes it may
be two months before I answer but
there's also a place there where you
know and I love it when do when people
do you know do shoot me at least you
know comments or things were thinking
about well at least two months isn't it
cosmic time scaling exactly right in the
grand scheme of things you waited a
little while for a reply but it wasn't
it wasn't millennia that's right it
wasn't yeah the earth hadn't switched
into a new climate stayed in that time
Adam thank you very much I've really
enjoyed this I'll make sure everything's
linked in the show notes below and enjoy
your birthday tomorrow thank you very
much sir cheers bye-bye Aaron bye-bye
[Music]